[Music]
easy game
at the chip in challenge we had 60
seconds to hit in as many as possible
they'll give us a little bit of a run
for our money but uh these young guys
are coming out firing so y'all better
bring y'all's a game i got my boy mike
there ready to catch i don't even know
who caught aaron devonte left him and
tyreek left you patrick josh don't worry
someone's gonna leave you too i love you
my boy mike never left me i'll tell you
that but anyway we're on the same team
aaron josh
and uh patrick aren't gonna get any so
you ready
three
two
[Music]
oh
[Music]
that won't be beat
leaving that won't
i think pat are going to help each other
out you play your game i play mine i'm
sure we'll come out with the win let's
go get this dove man line it up
[Applause]
nope
come on now
oh my goodness
nope rod and travis
jesus
oh little chili dip there
[Music]
ah i got one in jesus
all over it old men got it why are they
even in this is it supposed to be
competitive
it happens it'll be the one we'll give
them one could not knock it in you know
you got to save some shots for the match
june 1st baby